Gee, what do you mean by direction? Well, you're running. You're running. I'm a runner. I'm running forward. Most people run forward. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 149, recorded on September 25th, 2023. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we are back from the Slovenia 2023 road trip and record for the first time in almost four months. We chat about my new obsession with CityStrides.com and more. So, yeah. What's going on? How's it been?
Gee, what do you mean by direction? Well, you're running. You're running. I'm a runner. I'm running forward. Most people run forward. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 149, recorded on September 25th, 2023. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we are back from the Slovenia 2023 road trip and record for the first time in almost four months. We chat about my new obsession with CityStrides.com and more. So, yeah. What's going on? How's it been?|||天哪，你说的方向是什么意思？好吧，你在跑步。你在跑步。我是一个跑步者。我向前跑。大多数人向前跑。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 149 期，录制于 2023 年 9 月 25 日。我是康纳，今天与我的联合主持人布莱斯一起，我们结束了 2023 年斯洛文尼亚公路旅行归来，近四个月来首次进行录制。我们聊了聊我对 CityStrides.com 的新痴迷以及更多内容。所以，是的。最近怎么样？过得如何？
It's been a while. We haven't talked for a while. Yeah, I just got back from Europe. I got to meet Hana's dog. Hana has an Italian greyhound. Very adorable Italian greyhound. And that was a lot of fun. Although my dog hasn't forgiven me for uh for playing with and loving another dog this is for uh clarity for those that are not steeped in the c++ lore conference world hannah dusakova of ctre fame that is compile time regular expressions and i've seen she's actually been giving some
It's been a while. We haven't talked for a while. Yeah, I just got back from Europe. I got to meet Hana's dog. Hana has an Italian greyhound. Very adorable Italian greyhound. And that was a lot of fun. Although my dog hasn't forgiven me for uh for playing with and loving another dog this is for uh clarity for those that are not steeped in the c++ lore conference world hannah dusakova of ctre fame that is compile time regular expressions and i've seen she's actually been giving some|||好久不见了。我们有一段时间没聊天了。对，我刚从欧洲回来。我见到了哈娜的狗。哈娜有一只意大利灵缇犬。非常可爱的意大利灵缇犬。那真的很有趣。虽然我的狗还没原谅我“出轨”去跟另一只狗玩耍并疼爱它……为了给那些不太了解 C++ 传说和会议世界的人澄清一下，这里指的是因 CTRE（也就是编译期正则表达式）而闻名的哈娜·杜萨科娃（Hannah Dusakova），我看到她实际上一直在做一些……
i saw her gave a talk i can't remember if it was at c++ on c or it was some other i don't think it was c++ on c actually because i don't recall seeing her there but she gave a talk i can't remember if it was on coroutines or modules it was some she you know she she was showing me some of the stuff she's doing with coroutines right now. She wrote a library called co curl, like curl the command line tool for accessing a website and downloading stuff from websites. So she wrote like a C++ wrapper around curl that is coroutine, that's based on coroutines. It has a coroutine interface for managing asynchrony. And it's super, super cool and very slick.
i saw her gave a talk i can't remember if it was at c++ on c or it was some other i don't think it was c++ on c actually because i don't recall seeing her there but she gave a talk i can't remember if it was on coroutines or modules it was some she you know she she was showing me some of the stuff she's doing with coroutines right now. She wrote a library called co curl, like curl the command line tool for accessing a website and downloading stuff from websites. So she wrote like a C++ wrapper around curl that is coroutine, that's based on coroutines. It has a coroutine interface for managing asynchrony. And it's super, super cool and very slick.|||我看到她做过一次演讲，记不清是在 C++ on Sea 还是其他什么地方了。我觉得其实不是在 C++ on Sea，因为我不记得在那里见过她。但她做过一次演讲，我记不清是关于协程还是模块的了。那是某种……你知道的，她当时在向我展示她目前用协程在做的一些事情。她写了一个名为 co curl 的库，就像用于访问网站和从网站下载东西的命令行工具 curl 那样。所以她写了一个围绕 curl 的 C++ 包装器，它是基于协程的。它拥有一个用于管理异步性的协程接口。这真的是超级超级酷，而且非常精妙。
And she was showing me how it worked. And it does some very clever, clever things. She actually inspired a secret coroutine project that I'm working on that I can't talk about right now, but is also very cool. And I actually just did some interesting stuff with my secret curating project today but yeah it's uh she's given that talk um i think at a a meetup in uh the czech republic but she's about to give it uh at ndc tech town or i guess she's by, now she has given it at NDC Tech Town.
And she was showing me how it worked. And it does some very clever, clever things. She actually inspired a secret coroutine project that I'm working on that I can't talk about right now, but is also very cool. And I actually just did some interesting stuff with my secret curating project today but yeah it's uh she's given that talk um i think at a a meetup in uh the czech republic but she's about to give it uh at ndc tech town or i guess she's by, now she has given it at NDC Tech Town.|||她向我展示了它是如何工作的。它做了一些非常巧妙、非常聪明的事情。她实际上激发了我正在进行的一个秘密协程项目的灵感，我现在还不能谈论它，但它也非常酷。其实我今天刚对我的秘密协程项目做了一些有趣的事情。不过，是的，她已经在……我想是在捷克共和国的一次聚会上做过那个演讲，但她马上就要在 NDC Tech Town 做这个演讲了，或者我猜她现在已经、已经在 NDC Tech Town 做过这个演讲了。
When I saw her, she was just about to leave for NDC Tech Town. Yeah, that conference I think has just happened in, was it Kongsberg in Norway? It is Kongsberg in Norway, which is about an hour or so away from Oslo. I was considering going there for a day on my way out of Europe,
When I saw her, she was just about to leave for NDC Tech Town. Yeah, that conference I think has just happened in, was it Kongsberg in Norway? It is Kongsberg in Norway, which is about an hour or so away from Oslo. I was considering going there for a day on my way out of Europe,|||我见到她时，她正准备动身去 NDC Tech Town。对，那个会议我想刚刚在……是挪威的孔斯贝格（Kongsberg）举办的吗？就是在挪威的孔斯贝格，距离奥斯陆大约一个小时左右的车程。我曾考虑在离开欧洲的途中去那里待上一天，
but I had to get back to Milan from the Czech Republic to fly back to New York and figuring out how to get from the Czech Republic to Konzberg and then from Konzberg to Milan was just too complicated for me. In Milan, is that where you were for your wedding stuff? If I recall correctly? Uh, not a wedding. Uh, no, just a family trip. Um, and no, we were in Tuscany and it was amazing. Um, we had a great time. Uh, we stayed at this like villa, this 15th century Medici villa that my, uh, stepfather had rented out to get the whole family together. And it's a really cool tour company where they, they bring in all these, this like Italian chef who cooks for you for the
but I had to get back to Milan from the Czech Republic to fly back to New York and figuring out how to get from the Czech Republic to Konzberg and then from Konzberg to Milan was just too complicated for me. In Milan, is that where you were for your wedding stuff? If I recall correctly? Uh, not a wedding. Uh, no, just a family trip. Um, and no, we were in Tuscany and it was amazing. Um, had a great time. Uh, we stayed at this like villa, this 15th century Medici villa that my, uh, stepfather had rented out to get the whole family together. And it's a really cool tour company where they, they bring in all these, this like Italian chef who cooks for you for the|||但我必须从捷克共和国赶回米兰，以便飞回纽约，而弄清楚如何从捷克共和国到孔斯贝格，然后再从孔斯贝格到米兰，对我来说实在太复杂了。在米兰，那是你为了筹备婚礼待的地方吗？如果我没记错的话？呃，不是婚礼。呃，没有，只是一次家庭旅行。嗯，没有，我们在托斯卡纳，那太棒了。嗯，我们玩得很开心。呃，我们住在一栋别墅里，那是15th世纪的美第奇别墅，我……呃，继父租下来让全家人聚在一起的。那是一家非常酷的旅游公司，他们会请来所有这些……就像一个意大利厨师，为你烹饪
whole week. But like, she's, she's only a chef by night. Her, her, like her, her educational background is she has a PhD in geology and she's cooking dinner every night. And like one of the people who's the travel coordinator for this tour company has like a PhD in physics. They're all like super smart and interesting people in addition to being great hosts and tour guides. So we had like this very authentic, homey,
whole week. But like, she, she's, she's only a chef by night. Her, her, like her, her educational background is she has a PhD in geology and she's cooking dinner every night. And like one of the people who's the travel coordinator for this tour company has like a PhD in physics. They're all like super smart and interesting people in addition to being great hosts and tour guides. So we had like this very authentic, homey,|||整整一周的饭菜。但就像是，她、她只有在晚上才是个厨师。她、她的背景是她拥有地质学博士学位，然后她每天晚上都在做饭。而且，这家旅游公司的旅游协调员之一还拥有物理学博士学位。除了是优秀的东道主和导游之外，他们所有人都是超级聪明且有趣的人。所以我们有了这种非常真实、温馨的、
Italian experience where we had home-cooked meals every day. It was great and amazing. And then I, then after that, I went to Cicicchio to spend a couple days hanging out with Hana. I spent a day in Vienna. You and I spent a day in Vienna, but I spent a slightly longer day in Vienna. Technically, I spent two hours in one day in Vienna, and then I spent like a full day in Vienna. So I spent like a day and a half in Vienna. And then I spent a day and a half in Milan, and then I came back, and I just got home, and now I'm uh trying to recover and get back into the swing of things it's like the first vacation vacation I've taken in a
Italian experience where we had home-cooked meals every day. It was great and amazing. And then I, then after that, I went to Cicicchio to spend a couple days hanging out with Hana. I spent a day in Vienna. You and I spent a day in Vienna, but I spent a slightly longer day in Vienna. Technically, I spent two hours in one day in Vienna, and then I spent like a full day in Vienna. So I spent like a day and a half in Vienna. And then I spent a day and a half in Milan, and then I came back, and I just got home, and now I'm uh trying to recover and get back into the swing of things it's like the first vacation vacation I've taken in a|||意大利体验，每天都能吃到家常饭菜。感觉棒极了，太神奇了。然后我……在那之后，我去了奇奇基奥（Cicicchio），和哈娜一起闲逛了几天。我在维也纳呆了一天。你和我都在维也纳呆过一天，但我呆的时间稍微长了一点点。严格来说，我在维也纳的第一天呆了两个小时，然后我又在维也纳呆了一整天。所以我大概在维也纳呆了一个半天……哦不，一天半。然后我在米兰呆了一天半，接着我就回来了，刚到家，现在我……呃，在努力恢复状态，重新进入工作和生活的节奏。这好像是我……
while I'm uh I'm jealous you were in Milan Milan is on I was I was in Milan during fashion week well I could care less about fashion week what I care about there were there were a lot of pretty girls at fashion week not not you pretty sure ramona still doesn't listen to this podcast well ramona is actually within earshot so i'm sure she heard that uh all right good luck to you good luck to you but i mean we'll spend a whole episode on this because listen folks we haven't actually mentioned this but this is the first today is september 25th 2023 the last time you and i recorded bryce sitting behind our computers was may 31st that is yeah wow for almost exactly four months ago minus a couple days yeah we obviously recorded a bunch of times potentially too many times while we did our Slovenia 2023 road trip because it
while I'm uh I'm jealous you were in Milan Milan is on I was I was in Milan during fashion week well I could care less about fashion week what I care about there were there were a lot of pretty girls at fashion week not not you pretty sure ramona still doesn't listen to this podcast well ramona is actually within earshot so i'm sure she heard that uh all right good luck to you good luck to you but i mean we'll spend a whole episode on this because listen folks we haven't actually mentioned this but this is the first today is september 25th 2023 the last time you and i recorded bryce sitting behind our computers was may 31st that is yeah wow for almost exactly four months ago minus a couple days yeah we obviously recorded a bunch of times potentially too many times while we did our Slovenia 2023 road trip because it|||这段时间以来度过的第一个真正的假期。我……呃，我很嫉妒你在米兰。米兰在……我当时……我是在时装周期间在米兰的。好吧，我才不在乎什么时装周呢，我关心的是……时装周上有好多漂亮女孩。不是……不是你。我敢肯定雷蒙娜（Ramona）依然不听这个播客。好吧，雷蒙娜其实就在听得到的范围内，所以我敢肯定她听到那句话了。呃，好吧，祝你好运，祝你好运。不过，我的意思是，我们会用整整一期节目来聊这个，因为听好了各位，我们其实还没提过，但今天是……今天是 2023 年 9 月 25 日，你和我（布莱斯）上次坐在电脑前录音还是在 5 月 31 日，那是……对，哇，差不多正好是四个月前，只差几天。对，我们在进行 2023 年斯洛文尼亚公路旅行期间，显然录了很多次音，可能次数有点太多了，因为……
ended up I don't actually have the exact count but I think it was plus or minus like eight episodes and because we only do this weekly that's that's onesixth, that's 17% of our annual content. And how have those episodes been received? That's really the question. That really answers whether it was too much, is whether they're doing well or not. I think they're doing just as well. Honestly, I think at this point, I've been following the stats. We've kind of hit a plateau. Well, I guess it's, yeah, a plateau. But that kind of sounds bad. We have advanced to our level of incompetence. What?
ended up I don't actually have the exact count but I think it was plus or minus like eight episodes and because we only do this weekly that's that's onesixth, that's 17% of our annual content. And how have those episodes been received? That's really the question. That really answers whether it was too much, is whether they're doing well or not. I think they're doing just as well. Honestly, I think at this point, I've been following the stats. We've kind of hit a plateau. Well, I guess it's, yeah, a plateau. But that kind of sounds bad. We have advanced to our level of incompetence. What?|||结果……我其实没有确切的数字，但我觉得大概是正负八集左右。因为我们是每周更新一次，所以那……那占了我们全年内容的六分之一，即 17%。那些节目的反响如何？这才是真正的问题。真正能回答这是否过多的问题，是它们的表现到底好不好。我觉得它们的表现同样很好。老实说，我觉得就目前而言，我一直在关注统计数据，我们有点进入了瓶颈期。嗯，我想是的，对，一个瓶颈期。但这听起来有点糟糕。我们已经晋升到了我们无能的水平。什么？
It's like a thing. I'll find the reference. Yeah, find a link and we'll put it in the show notes. I'm confused. But I think it's at this point within, I think, a week or two, it's usually a couple thousand downloads, according to the site. Who knows how accurate it is? And then within a month or two, it peaks at about 3,000. And I think that's been level for now half a year, a year, something like that. So the reference is the Peter Principle, which is a concept in
It's like a thing. I'll find the reference. Yeah, find a link and we'll put it in the show notes. I'm confused. But I think it's at this point within, I think, a week or two, it's usually a couple thousand downloads, according to the site. Who knows how accurate it is? And then within a month or two, it peaks at about 3,000. And I think that's been level for now half a year, a year, something like that. So the reference is the Peter Principle, which is a concept in|||这就像是个梗。我会找到出处的。对，找个链接，我们会把它放在节目说明（show notes）里。我很困惑。但我认为就目前而言，根据网站显示，通常在一两周内就会有几千次下载。谁知道它有多准确呢？然后在的一两个月内，下载量会达到约 3,000 次的峰值。而且我认为这种情况已经持平了半年、一年，诸如此类的。所以这个梗就是“彼得原理”（Peter Principle），这是一个……
management developed by Lawrence J. Peter, which observes that people in a hierarchy tend to rise to a level of respective incompetence. So you get promoted based on your success in previous jobs until you reach a level at which you are no longer competent. And I think that applies here, too. Oh, I see. We have become successful enough. We've gotten to a certain level where we now have an audience. And we're-
management developed by Lawrence J. Peter, which observes that people in a hierarchy tend to rise to a level of respective incompetence. So you get promoted based on your success in previous jobs until you reach a level at which you are no longer competent. And I think that applies here, too. Oh, I see. We have become successful enough. We've gotten to a certain level where we now have an audience. And we're-|||由劳伦斯·J·彼得（Lawrence J. Peter）提出的管理学概念，它观察到：在层级组织中，人们倾向于晋升到他们各自不称职的级别。所以你会根据你在先前工作中的成功而不断晋升，直到达到你不再胜任的级别。我觉得这也适用于这里。哦，我明白了。我们已经足够成功了。我们已经达到了某个水平，现在有了一定的听众。而且我们正……
I disagree. We're still, we may be at a temporary plateau, but I have great plans for the pod. I mean, I think the traveling, the trip angle I think is, is really a, a fascinating thing that might, might take us to a whole new horizons. Yeah.
I disagree. We're still, we may be at a temporary plateau, but I have great plans for the pod. I mean, I think the traveling, the trip angle I think is, is really a, a fascinating thing that might, might take us to a whole new horizons. Yeah.|||我不同意。我们仍然……我们可能处于一个暂时的瓶颈期，但我对播客有伟大的计划。我的意思是，我觉得旅行、旅行这个角度，真的……是一个迷人的东西，它可能会、可能会把我们带向全新的境界。是的。
I mean, I, I really do hope that the listeners are enjoying and being entertained by our antics on the road. That being said, I mean, I have so much fun. I mean that three episode,
I mean, I, I really do hope that the listeners are enjoying and being entertained by our antics on the road. That being said, I mean, I have so much fun. I mean that three episode,|||我是说，我真的希望听众们能喜欢并享受我们在路上的种种滑稽行径。话虽如此，我是说，我玩得太开心了。我是指那三集……
which was just all one hour and a half bit when we were interviewing Sean at C plus plus on C not only is that like one of the highlights of this podcast for me, that's like one of the highlights of my life. Yeah, that was, that was a ton of fun. And,
which was just all one hour and a half bit when we were interviewing Sean at C plus plus on C not only is that like one of the highlights of this podcast for me, that's like one of the highlights of my life. Yeah, that was, that was a ton of fun. And,|||那完全是整整一个半小时的片段，当时我们在 C++ on Sea 采访肖恩（Sean）。那不仅是我认为这个播客的亮点之一，那简直是我人生中的亮点之一。对，那真的……真的超级好玩。而且，
and on it. So I, I looked at some of the comments on the interview that we, uh, we just put in the last episode on Rob Leahy. Leahy? Rob, you're a dear friend of mine. I hope you're not listening to me butchering your name.
and on it. So I, I looked at some of the comments on the interview that we, uh, we just put in the last episode on Rob Leahy. Leahy? Rob, you're a dear friend of mine. I hope you're not listening to me butchering your name.|||在上面。所以，我……我看了一些关于我们不久前在上一期节目中发布的关于罗布·利希（Rob Leahy）的采访的评论。利希？罗布，你是我的挚友。我希望你没有听到我在糟蹋你的名字。
But we interviewed Rob in Venice, and there were two comments on Reddit, and both of them were, like, positive comments. And I was just like, wow. Like, we did a good job. And I haven't checked since, so nobody ruined it for me, but like a hundred percent when I, at the time I looked, it was a hundred percent positive feedback. And it wasn't just like, oh, this is an okay episode. It was like, one of them was like amazing. And the other one was like unreal. Wow.
But we interviewed Rob in Venice, and there were two comments on Reddit, and both of them were, like, positive comments. And I was just like, wow. Like, we did a good job. And I haven't checked since, so nobody ruined it for me, but like a hundred percent when I, at the time I looked, it was a hundred percent positive feedback. And it wasn't just like, oh, this is an okay episode. It was like, one of them was like amazing. And the other one was like unreal. Wow.|||但我们在威尼斯采访了罗布，Reddit 上有两个评论，而且两个都是正面的评价。当时我就想，哇塞。感觉我们干得真不错。从那之后我就没再查看过了，所以千万别有人破坏我的好心情，但在我当时查看的时候，百分之百全是正面反馈。而且不只是那种“哦，这集还行”的评价，其中一个评价简直是“太棒了”，另一个则是“简直难以置信”。哇。
Yeah, actually I hadn't, uh, I hadn't been keeping up with that. That's good to hear. I mean, that, that, that episode as well. I just honestly, it is some of those episodes. I mean, I was thinking we should correspond our conferences next year because I want to try and prioritize conferences that I haven't been to. I know you've been to Core CPP. Have you been to NDC Tech Town? I have not been to NDC Tech Town. I have not been to Core CPP. But the thing is, is if we both go to the same conferences, we can do little, you know, interviewing speakers slash
Yeah, actually I hadn't, uh, I hadn't been keeping up with that. That's good to hear. I mean, that, that, that episode as well. I just honestly, it is some of those episodes. I mean, I was thinking we should correspond our conferences next year because I want to try and prioritize conferences that I haven't been to. I know you've been to Core CPP. Have you been to NDC Tech Town? I have not been to NDC Tech Town. I have not been to Core CPP. But the thing is, is if we both go to the same conferences, we can do little, you know, interviewing speakers slash|||对，其实我……我一直没怎么关注那个。听到这个消息真好。我是说，那一集也是。说实话，有些这样的节目……我是说我在想，我们明年的会议行程应该协调一下，因为我想试着优先去那些我没去过的会议。我知道你去过 Core CPP。你去过 NDC Tech Town 吗？我没去过 NDC Tech Town。我也没去过 Core CPP。但问题是，如果我们俩去同一个会议，我们就可以做点……你知道的，采访演讲者或者……
attendees. I mean, we, I think historically have tended to focus on interviewing the speakers and podcast hosts like we did at C++ on C. But I think it would be fun to like, if we're giving out stickers, like we still don't have stickers yet, but we will have stickers in the future. And if we're giving them out, you know, just getting like little two minute, three minute, you know, sound bites from attendees that, you know, aren't recognizable names or anything of just like, you know, what is this your first conference, you know, second conference, how are you enjoying it, etc. I think that is, you know, really fun and just like a great way to connect with the community and you know, people that you don't already know. Anyways, we'll save that for another episode. I was you something up and then i said this is the first time we're
attendees. I mean, we, I think historically have tended to focus on interviewing the speakers and podcast hosts like we did at C++ on C. But I think it would be fun to like, if we're giving out stickers, like we still don't have stickers yet, but we will have stickers in the future. And if we're giving them out, you know, just getting like little two minute, three minute, you know, sound bites from attendees that, you know, aren't recognizable names or anything of just like, you know, what is this your first conference, you know, second conference, how are you enjoying it, etc. I think that is, you know, really fun and just like a great way to connect with the community and you know, people that you don't already know. Anyways, we'll save that for another episode. I was you something up and then i said this is the first time we're|||与会者。我的意思是，回顾过去，我们往往倾向于专注于采访演讲者和播客主持人，就像我们在 C++ on Sea 做的那样。但我觉得很有趣的一点是，如果我们发放贴纸（虽然我们现在还没有贴纸，但以后会有的），如果我们发放贴纸的话，顺便从那些并非什么知名人物的与会者那里获取两三分钟的简短采访录音，比如问问“这是你第一次参加会议吗，还是第二次？你觉得体验怎么样？”等等。我觉得这……你知道的，真的很有趣，而且是与社区以及你不认识的人建立联系的一种绝佳方式。不管怎样，我们把这个留在另一期节目再聊吧。我刚才……
recording oh and then i said yes we're going to dedicate a whole episode to this at some point in the future but you went to milan yeah and i'm jealous that you went to milan because that is on my list of cities to visit and spend some time in because you do know this because you actually referred to it when we were walking in Venice and I was collecting the nodes, but I have become like, uh, obsessed like it to say, I can't remember who said it once that I don't have passions. I have obsessions, but like if I was, you know, focused on city strides and collecting nodes back in June, I am now like a full blown like addict. I have gone and written two, well, technically I wrote one Python graph algorithm to generate like optimal routes and I've become like a open street map. I wouldn't say expert,
recording oh and then i said yes we're going to dedicate a whole episode to this at some point in the future but you went to milan yeah and i'm jealous that you went to milan because that is on my list of cities to visit and spend some time in because you do know this because you actually referred to it when we were walking in Venice and I was collecting the nodes, but I have become like, uh, obsessed like it to say, I can't remember who said it once that I don't have passions. I have obsessions, but like if I was, you know, focused on city strides and collecting nodes back in June, I am now like a full blown like addict. I have gone and written two, well, technically I wrote one Python graph algorithm to generate like optimal routes and I've become like a open street map. I wouldn't say expert,|||录音……哦，然后我说，是的，我们在未来的某个时候会用整整一期节目来专门聊这个。不过你去了米兰，对，我很嫉妒你去了米兰，因为那在我的“要去访问并度过一段时间的城市”清单上。因为你其实知道这一点，因为我们在威尼斯散步、而我在收集节点时你还专门提过。但我现在变得……呃，极其痴迷，正如有人曾说过的那样（我记不清是谁说的了）——我没有激情，我只有执念。但就像……如果在今年 6 月时我还在专注于 CityStrides 和收集节点的话，我现在简直就成了一个彻头彻尾的“瘾君子”。我甚至去写了两个……好吧，严格来说我写了一个 Python 图论算法来生成类似最优路线的东西，我甚至快成了 OpenStreetMap……我不能说我是专家，
but there's like an equivalent, an open source equivalent. We're going to, we're going to talk about that Python script in a little bit. Yeah. Well, I wrote it initially in Python. And then I was like, this is too slow. I need to speed it up. Let's convert it to, you know, Rust. Why not? And I just got ChatGPT to do it. And it worked amazingly, man. Nice.
and there's like an equivalent, an open source equivalent. We're going to, we're going to talk about that Python script in a little bit. Yeah, Well, I wrote it initially in Python. And then I was like, this is too slow. I need to speed it up. Let's convert it to, you know, Rust. Why not? And I just got ChatGPT to do it. And it worked amazingly, man. Nice.|||但有一个同类工具，一个开源的同类工具。我们待会儿会……会聊聊那个 Python 脚本。对，好吧，我最初是用 Python 写的。然后我觉得，这太慢了，我得给它提提速。把它转换成……你知道的，Rust 吧，为什么不呢？于是我就让 ChatGPT 帮我搞定了。结果它运行得惊人地好，老兄。太棒了。
And anyways, my point is I've become very much obsessed. And I'm going to be – I said this on my other podcast as well, that I'm currently ranked – I think at the time on my other podcast, I was ranked 116th. I'm now ranked 114th. I will be ranked number one in my lifetime, probably within the next few years. I'm thinking about even starting like a vlog series of like, you know,
And anyways, my point is I've become very much obsessed. And I'm going to be – I said this on my other podcast as well, that I'm currently ranked – I think at the time on my other podcast, I was ranked 116th. I'm now ranked 114th. I will be ranked number one in my lifetime, probably within the next few years. I'm thinking about even starting like a vlog series of like, you know,|||总而言之，我的意思是，我已经变得非常痴迷了。而且我将要……我在我的另一个播客里也说过这一点，我目前排在……我想当时在我的另一个播客里，我排名第 116 位。我现在排名第 114 位。我有生之年一定会排到第一名，大概就在未来几年内。我甚至在考虑开一个 vlog 系列，比如……
running the world, and it's going to be half running, half programming, because it's Python, Rust, exciting. Anyways, we have a couple things to... Wait, wait, wait. I want to hear more about your script. What algorithm the G is. So, wait, why don't you first describe in a short and concise fashion the problem that you're trying to solve and then tell me how you go about solving it.
running the world, and it's going to be half running, half programming, because it's Python, Rust, exciting. Anyways, we have a couple things to... Wait, wait, wait. I want to hear more about your script. What algorithm the G is. So, wait, why don't you first describe in a short and concise fashion the problem that you're trying to solve and then tell me how you go about solving it.|||奔跑世界，内容将是“一半跑步，一半编程”，因为有 Python，有 Rust，太令人兴奋了。不管怎样，我们有几件事要……等等，等等，等等。我想听听更多关于你的脚本的事。G 是什么算法。所以，等等，你为什么不先用简短精炼的方式描述一下你试图解决的问题，然后告诉我你是如何着手解决它的呢？
It's very complicated. But so before I jump into what will hopefully be less than a two-minute explanation of this algorithm, I have a list of things that were comments, things that we need to mention in the first episode back because it's been four months since we've recorded, not on the road, not at a conference. So we're catching up. We're going to address a comment from Andrew Craig on Twitter about the R pipeline from episode 143. We are going to read a comment from the GitHub discussion on episode 142 with respect to Rust. And we'll do that stuff at some point.
It's very complicated. But so before I jump into what will hopefully be less than a two-minute explanation of this algorithm, I have a list of things that were comments, things that we need to mention in the first episode back because it's been four months since we've recorded, not on the road, not at a conference. So we're catching up. We're going to address a comment from Andrew Craig on Twitter about the R pipeline from episode 143. We are going to read a comment from the GitHub discussion on episode 142 with respect to Rust. And we'll do that stuff at some point.|||这非常复杂。不过，在我开始阐述这个算法（希望能在两分钟内解释清楚）之前，我列出了一系列评论，也就是我们在这期回归的首期节目中需要提及的事情，因为我们已经有四个月没有进行这种“既不在路上、也不在会议现场”的常规录音了。所以我们在叙旧。我们将回应 Andrew Craig 在 Twitter 上关于第 143 期节目中 R 管道（pipeline）的评论。我们将阅读第 142 期节目中关于 Rust 的 GitHub 讨论区的一条评论。我们会在某个时刻处理这些事情。
All right. I don't know. Start the timer. We'll see if it's 120 seconds or less. The problem is, given a set of nodes that define streets, or what are called ways on a open source version of Google Maps called OpenStreetMaps, which from henceforth will be referred to as OSM, you get these nodes that define streets, and you want to generate a path that is kind of like a traveling salesman path but it you were trying to optimize so so can i ask a question when you say nodes here um i'm thinking
All right. I don't know. Start the timer. We'll see if it's 120 seconds or less. The problem is, given a set of nodes that define streets, or what are called ways on a open source version of Google Maps called OpenStreetMaps, which from henceforth will be referred to as OSM, you get these nodes that define streets, and you want to generate a path that is kind of like a traveling salesman path but it you were trying to optimize so so can i ask a question when you say nodes here um i'm thinking|||好吧。我不知道。开始计时吧。我们来看看是不是 120 秒或更短。问题是，给定一组定义街道的节点，或者在名为 OpenStreetMaps（此后简称 OSM，即谷歌地图的开源版本）上被称为“路（way）”的东西，你得到了这些定义街道的节点，然后你想要生成一条路径，这有点像旅行商路径，但你是在试图进行优化……所以……所以我能问个问题吗？你在这里说“节点”时，嗯，我在想……
about this in terms of graph theory and usually when i think of like nodes in terms of graph theory i think of them as being like the points um the vertices. Yes. But streets, like in a graph, I would imagine are edges. Well, so imagine you have a neighborhood that is all straight streets. Nodes are basically like the minimal set of, I don't want to say intersections, but points that define the roads that represent them. And so a way, which is very confusing. So if you go to, I'll leave some links in the description. If you go to either Overpass or the OpenStreetMap website, they have all these metadata for describing the world.
about this in terms of graph theory and usually when i think of like nodes in terms of graph theory i think of them as being like the points um the vertices. Yes. But streets, like in a graph, I would imagine are edges. Well, so imagine you have a neighborhood that is all straight streets. Nodes are basically like the minimal set of, I don't want to say intersections, but points that define the roads that represent them. And so a way, which is very confusing. So if you go to, I'll leave some links in the description. If you go to either Overpass or the OpenStreetMap website, they have all these metadata for describing the world.|||从图论的角度来考虑这个问题，通常当我在图论的语境下想到节点时，我认为它们就像是点，嗯，顶点。是的。但街道，在图中，我想象中应该是边。好吧，所以想象一下，你有一个全都是笔直街道的社区。节点基本上就像是……我不想说是交叉路口，而是定义代表它们的道路的点。因此，“路（way）”这个概念非常令人困惑。所以如果你去……我会在简介中留一些链接。如果你去 Overpass 或者 OpenStreetMap 网站，它们有所有这些用于描述世界的元数据。
And basically every single institution, street, park, everything is represented in this database. And it's hundreds of gigabytes, if not, you know, what is that, terabytes of info. And you can zip it up and download it for Canada, Italy, wherever you want, America. And what they describe as streets, they actually label as ways, technically highways. And those represent everything, like footpaths bicycle paths highways residential areas and so a road is basically a highway or a way and a way is represented by a list of nodes in order so if you've got a simple street that's just straight it's probably just going to be two nodes okay one at the beginning one at the end if you've got a curved street
And basically every single institution, street, park, everything is represented in this database. And it's hundreds of gigabytes, if not, you know, what is that, terabytes of info. And you can zip it up and download it for Canada, Italy, wherever you want, America. And what they describe as streets, they actually label as ways, technically highways. And those represent everything, like footpaths bicycle paths highways residential areas and so a road is basically a highway or a way and a way is represented by a list of nodes in order so if you've got a simple street that's just straight it's probably just going to be two nodes okay one at the beginning one at the end if you've got a curved street|||基本上每个机构、街道、公园、所有东西都表示在这个数据库中。而且它有数百 GB，如果不是……你知道的，那是多少，数 TB 的信息。你可以把它打包成 zip 并下载加拿大、意大利、任何你想去的国家或美国的数据。他们所描述的街道，实际上被标记为“路（ways）”，技术上被称为“高速公路（highways）”。这些代表了一切，比如人行道、自行车道、高速公路、住宅区……所以一条路基本上就是一条 highway 或 way，而一个 way 是由按顺序排列的一份节点列表来表示的。所以如果你有一条很简单的笔直街道，它可能就只有两个节点，好吧，一个在起点，一个在终点。如果你有一条弯曲的街道，
you're going to end up with a bunch of nodes because you have to represent that curve with a bunch of basically straight subcomponents. So if you have a very curvy road, you're going to end up with like, you know, 50 nodes, even though it might be shorter than a straight street that has two nodes. And so basically you can build yourself a graph that represents the area you want to run. And currently I have a parameters dot YAML file. So I basically enter a city, enter a starting node, enter a distance in kilometers. And then there's a bunch of things that tweak how the algorithm works. And the goal of the algorithm, it'll improve over time. But currently the goal is just to find the path that completes the maximum number of streets possible. Oh, interesting.
you're going to end up with a bunch of nodes because you have to represent that curve with a bunch of basically straight subcomponents. So if you have a very curvy road, you're going to end up with like, you know, 50 nodes, even though it might be shorter than a straight street that has two nodes. And so basically you can build yourself a graph that represents the area you want to run. And currently I have a parameters dot YAML file. So I basically enter a city, enter a starting node, enter a distance in kilometers. And then there's a bunch of things that tweak how the algorithm works. And the goal of the algorithm, it'll improve over time. But currently the goal is just to find the path that completes the maximum number of streets possible. Oh, interesting.|||你最终会得到一堆节点，因为你必须用一堆基本上是直线的子组件来表示那个曲线。所以如果你有一条非常弯曲的道路，你最终可能会得到比如 50 个节点，尽管它可能比只有两个节点的笔直街道还要短。所以基本上你可以构建一个代表你想要跑步区域的图。目前我有一个 parameters.yaml 文件。所以我基本上是输入一个城市，输入一个起始节点，输入以公里为单位的距离。然后有一堆东西用来调整算法的工作方式。该算法的目标——它会随着时间推移而改进——但目前的目标只是找到一条能够完成尽可能多街道的路径。哦，有意思。
So it's probably some – you're in the given distance. Yes. So it's interesting because what you have here is both a graph theory problem and an optimization problem. Exactly. Yeah, I'm trying to think about what is there some some classical algorithm to uh yeah there's a bunch of algorithms like hamiltonian paths which complete everything and that's the thing is in the future i want two different algorithms one for when i'm living somewhere like toronto and my goal is to complete every street in the city. So every time I go on a run,
So it's probably some – you're in the given distance. Yes. So it's interesting because what you have here is both a graph theory problem and an optimization problem. Exactly. Yeah, I'm trying to think about what is there some some classical algorithm to uh yeah there's a bunch of algorithms like hamiltonian paths which complete everything and that's the thing is in the future i want two different algorithms one for when i'm living somewhere like toronto and my goal is to complete every street in the city. So every time I go on a run,|||所以它可能是一些……你在给定的距离内。是的。所以很有趣，因为你这里面对的既是一个图论问题，也是一个优化问题。完全正确。是的，我在思考有什么经典的算法来……是的，有一堆算法，比如哈密顿路径（Hamiltonian paths），它可以遍历所有东西。这就是关键所在，将来我想要两种不同的算法：一种用于当我住在像多伦多这样地方的时候，我的目标是跑完城市里的每一条街道。所以每次我去跑步时，
I don't want to leave any nodes left behind because that means on my next run, I have to go and run two kilometers to one node that I missed. That's super inefficient. So you basically want like a no node left behind algorithm that also is as efficient as possible. And that's the thing. There are a bunch of city striders
I don't want to leave any nodes left behind because that means on my next run, I have to go and run two kilometers to one node that I missed. That's super inefficient. So you basically want like a no node left behind algorithm that also is as efficient as possible. And that's the thing. There are a bunch of city striders|||我不想落下任何节点，因为这意味着在我的下一次跑步中，我必须去跑两公里去够一个我漏掉的节点。那超级没有效率。所以你基本上想要一个“不落下任何节点”的算法，同时还要尽可能高效。就是这样。有一群 CityStirde 跑者……
that call themselves purists that aren't actually trying to do street completion efficiently. They're actually trying to run every meter of every street so they have a pretty looking picture afterwards. I could care less about being a purist. I want to run as little as possible in order to get as quickly up the leaderboards as possible, right? Because you could imagine if you're in a neighborhood that's just like rectangular and you've got a bunch of streets that all just have two nodes that are parallel to each other, I could do it like a zigzag up and down each street, or I could just run like east to west at the top and then hop down to the bottom and then run west to east and then complete all of them without actually running any of the streets.
that call themselves purists that aren't actually trying to do street completion efficiently. They're actually trying to run every meter of every street so they have a pretty looking picture afterwards. I could care less about being a purist. I want to run as little as possible in order to get as quickly up the leaderboards as possible, right? Because you could imagine if you're in a neighborhood that's just like rectangular and you've_got a bunch of streets that all just have two nodes that are parallel to each other, I could do it like a zigzag up and down each street, or I could just run like east to west at the top and then hop down to the bottom and then run west to east and then complete all of them without actually running any of the streets.|||他们自称为“纯粹主义者”，实际上并没有试图高效地完成街道。他们实际上试图跑过每条街道的每一米，这样他们事后就能拥有一张好看的地图。我才不在乎当什么纯粹主义者呢。我想尽可能少跑，以便尽可能快地在排行榜上上升，对吧？因为你可以想象，如果你在一个像长方形一样的社区里，而且你有一堆街道，它们都只有两个互相平行的节点，我可以像之字形一样在每条街道上下穿梭，或者我可以直接在顶部从东向西跑，然后跳到底部，再从西向东跑，然后把它们全部完成，而实际上并不需要跑完所有的街道。
That question of you have all the nodes in the city, and you want to find the shortest possible route that visits each one. Not each one, a subset. Because in a city like Toronto, you have literally like 10,000 kilometers. You want to pick a starting node within a given distance, like 20 kilometers, complete as many as you can. Play along with me for a minute here. So you have all the nodes in the city. And suppose you want to find the shortest possible path that will visit each one of those nodes. Yeah, that's just traveling salesman. Exactly. That's what I was getting at.
That question of you have all the nodes in the city, and you want to find the shortest possible route that visits each one. Not each one, a subset. Because in a city like Toronto, you have literally like 10,000 kilometers. You want to pick a starting node within a given distance, like 20 kilometers, complete as many as you can. Play along with me for a minute here. So you have all the nodes in the city. And suppose you want to find the shortest possible path that will visit each one of those nodes. Yeah, that's just traveling salesman. Exactly. That's what I was getting at.|||“拥有城市中的所有节点，并且想要找到访问每一个节点的最短可能路线”这个问题……不是每一个，是一个子集。因为在像多伦多这样的城市里，你实际上有大约 10,000 公里。你想要在给定距离内（比如 20 公里）挑选一个起始节点，尽可能多地完成任务。在这里陪我玩一分钟思维游戏。所以你有城市里的所有节点。假设你想找到一条能访问所有这些节点的最短可能路径。是的，那就是旅行商问题（Traveling Salesperson）。完全正确。这就是我要说的。
And so I wonder if that knowledge that there's an existing well-known computer science problem here. I wonder whether that could help you research what the optimal algorithms are to tackle the actual problem that you're interested in, which is, I think, of a related family. And of course, there's another graph theory problem, which is fairly common in computer science, which is the shortest path problem, which is that like, you've got a graph, um, uh, find the, the shortest path through that graph. Um, yeah, those don't really help, or at least, I mean, I already, I already, you know, studied that at some point and that's not really like, this is the objective of this has nothing to do with like the, the distance covered
And so I wonder if that knowledge that there's an existing well-known computer science problem here. I wonder whether that could help you research what the optimal algorithms are to tackle the actual problem that you're interested in, which is, I think, of a related family. And of course, there's another graph theory problem, which is fairly common in computer science, which is the shortest path problem, which is that like, you've got a graph, um, uh, find the, the shortest path through that graph. Um, yeah, those don't really help, or at least, I mean, I already, I already, you know, studied that at some point and that's not really like, this is the objective of this has nothing to do with like, the, the distance covered|||因此，我在想，既然知道这里存在一个现成的、众所周知的计算机科学问题，我不知道这是否能帮你在研究中弄清楚什么是应对你实际感兴趣的问题的最优算法——我认为这个问题属于相关的家族。当然，还有另一个在计算机科学中相当常见的图论问题，那就是最短路径问题（Shortest Path Problem），即给定一个图，呃，找出穿过该图的最短路径。嗯，是的，那些并没有什么真正的帮助，或者至少，我是说，我已经……我已经，你知道的，在某个时候研究过那些了，那其实并不是……这个的目标与……所走过的距离无关。
with respect to streets completed matters but like actual shortest distance uh from point a to point b doesn't sure but uh explain to me why that why why why why the shortest path problem isn't a related thing i mean it's just it's the objective function of shortest path is shortest path point between point A and point B. Like, whereas, yeah, my main goal has nothing to do with like, like, I do have in my objective function of which path to choose while I'm running my algorithm does have something that basically divides the number of streets. You do want to maximize number of nodes, right? Number of streets you do want to maximize number of nodes right number of streets but yes um but so then maybe the shortest path problem gives you the uh the the minimum distance and and perhaps the inverse of that an inverse problem is how do you maximize um especially if you think about a weighted graph um like what what you really want to do is,
with respect to streets completed matters but like actual shortest distance uh from point a to point b doesn't sure but uh explain to me why that why why why why the shortest path problem isn't a related thing i mean it's just it's the objective function of shortest path is shortest path point between point A and point B. Like, whereas, yeah, my main goal has nothing to do with like, like, I do have in my objective function of which path to choose while I'm running my algorithm does have something that basically divides the number of streets. You do want to maximize number of nodes, right? Number of streets you do want to maximize number of nodes right number of streets but yes um but so then maybe the shortest path problem gives you the – the minimum distance and and perhaps the inverse of that an inverse problem is how do you maximize – especially if you think about a weighted graph – like what what you really want to do is,|||就完成的街道而言，这确实很重要，但从 A 点到 B 点的实际最短距离……没关系。当然，但是……向我解释一下为什么最短路径问题不是一个相关的事情？我的意思是，这只是……最短路径的目标函数是 A 点和 B 点之间的最短路径点。而在我看来，是的，我的主要目标与此无关，就像……在我的算法运行时选择哪条路径的目标函数中，确实包含了一些基本上除以街道数量的东西。你确实想要最大化节点的数量，对吧？街道的数量……你确实想要最大化节点的数量，对吧？街道的数量……但是是的，嗯……但也许最短路径问题能为你提供最小距离，或许它的逆问题——一个逆问题是：如何最大化……特别是如果你考虑一个加权图的话——你真正想做的是，
given some weighted graph where the edges have weights, how do you maximize the number of nodes that you visit while also... How do you get the maximum nodes visited per weight of edge takings? See what I'm saying? Yeah, and I do have something like that, not using the weight of edges, but while I'm...
given some weighted graph where the edges have weights, how do you maximize the number of nodes that you visit while also... How do you get the maximum nodes visited per weight of edge takings? See what I'm saying? Yeah, and I do have something like that, not using the weight of edges, but while I'm...|||给定某个边具有权重的加权图，如何在最大化你访问的节点数量的同时……如何做到每付出单位边权重的代价，访问到最多的节点？明白我的意思吗？是的，我确实有类似的东西，不是使用边的权重，而是在我……
I basically have... I haven't even really described it. We should explain. The weight of edges here is the distance between the two nodes because in these graphs that we're describing here, not all nodes are equidistant. Maybe in a city like Venice, there are like two nodes that are like, you know, 10 meters apart, but in a more rural area, you
I basically have... I haven't even really described it. We should explain. The weight of edges here is the distance between the two nodes because in these graphs that we're describing here, not all nodes are equidistant. Maybe in a city like Venice, there are like two nodes that are like, you know, 10 meters apart, but in a more rural area, you|||我基本上有……我甚至还没有真正描述它。我们应该解释一下。这里的边权重是两个节点之间的距离，因为在我们这里描述的这些图中，并非所有节点都等距。也许在像威尼斯这样的城市里，有些节点彼此相距，你知道的，10米，但在更偏远的乡村地区，
know, two nodes may be like a kilometer or two kilometers apart. And so obviously your algorithm needs to account for that. And so the way that you do that is you assign a weight to the edges. Yeah. I mean, I don't do any weight assigning to edges. What I do is. Well, you probably consider the distance. I do. I do. So like the distance is the weight. I mean, sure. You can explain it that way. I would not explain it that way. Cause that's not, I don't have a weighted graph. I do not have a graph that calculates uh the distance of each street and then you know explores based on maybe you're doing it wrong well if you understood the i have like literally in these cities hundreds of thousands of nodes and the dimensionality of the problem
know, two nodes may be like a kilometer or two kilometers apart. And so obviously your algorithm needs to account for that. And so the way that you do that is you assign a weight to the edges. Yeah. I mean, I don't do any weight assigning to edges. What I do is. Well, you probably consider the distance. I do. I do. So like the distance is the weight. I mean, sure. You can explain it that way. I would not explain it that way. Cause that's not, I don't have a weighted graph. I do not have a graph that calculates uh the distance of each street and then you know explores based on maybe you're doing it wrong well if you understood the i have like literally in these cities hundreds of thousands of nodes and the dimensionality of the problem|||你知道，两个节点可能相距一公里或两公里。所以显然你的算法需要考虑到这一点。你实现这一点的方法就是给边赋予权重。是的。我的意思是，我没有对边进行任何权重分配。我做的是……好吧，你可能考虑了距离。我考虑了。我考虑了。所以距离就是权重。我是说，当然。你可以那样解释。我不会那样解释。因为那不是……我没有一个加权图。我没有一个图去计算……呃，每条街道的距离，然后你知道的，根据……也许你做错了。好吧，如果你理解了……我在这些城市里实际上有数十万个节点，这个问题的维度……
is like the hardest thing this is not like a simple graph problem like and and there's an extra layer of that the streets that i am trying to complete are basically one query where it ignores a bunch of you know private thing private roads and unwalkable roads and highways like you know high traffic highways and like overpasses and stuff like that and you and and it also the key thing is that you only a road is only completable if it's named if it doesn't have a name uh it it's not it doesn't show up on city strides as something to be completed however in order to build your path you need all roads whether they're named oh that's interesting so so and so I'm traversing based on one set of data and then calculating my roads,
is like the hardest thing this is not like a simple graph problem like and and there's an extra layer of that the streets that i am trying to complete are basically one query where it ignores a bunch of you know private thing private roads and unwalkable roads and highways like you know high traffic highways and like overpasses and stuff like that and you and and it also the key thing is that you only a road is only completable if it's named if it doesn't have a name uh it it's not it doesn't show up on city strides as something to be completed however in order to build your path you need all roads whether they're named oh that's interesting so so and so I'm traversing based on one set of data and then calculating my roads,|||简直是最难的部分。这不像是一个简单的图问题，而且还有另一层因素：我试图完成的街道基本上是通过一个查询得到的，该查询会忽略一堆私人领地、私人道路、不可步行的道路以及高速公路，比如你知道的高流量高速公路、立交桥之类东西。而且……而且关键在于，一条路只有在有名字的情况下才是可以完成的；如果它没有名字，呃，它就不会在 CityStrides 上显示为需要完成的东西。然而，为了构建你的路径，你需要所有的道路，不管它们有没有名字。哦，这很有意思。所以……所以……所以我遍历使用的是一套数据，然后计算我的道路……
my streets completed on another set of data. Is it possible that for a given city that there may be, that the graph may not be connected? I don't think so. I mean, I ran into that at one point and that's how I discovered that I needed two sets of data
my streets completed on another set of data. Is it possible that for a given city that there may be, that the graph may not be connected? I don't think so. I mean, I ran into that at one point and that-s how I discovered that I needed two sets of data|||我完成的街道是通过另一套数据计算的。对于给定的城市，会不会存在图不连通的情况？我觉得不会。我的意思是，我曾经遇到过一次这种情况，也就是那时我发现我需要两套数据，
because I was running this algorithm in Bangkok and it would never, it seemed like my algorithm should go one direction where there was this really dense collection of nodes because i have a part of my algorithm is what i call hot spot seeking because it's not like i have a greedy algorithm that works iteratively that goes and just tries to look at the next 10 steps and find the best path and then basically repetitively do that but at a certain point it runs out of path and then basically repetitively do that. But at a certain point, it runs out of stuff and then it just arbitrarily starts choosing a direction. And really what you want is in a certain city, if there is a really, really dense collection of
because I was running this algorithm in Bangkok and it would never, it seemed like my algorithm should go one direction where there was this really dense collection of nodes because i have a part of my algorithm is what i call hot spot seeking because it's not like i have a greedy algorithm that works iteratively that goes and just tries to look at the next 10 steps and find the best path and then basically repetitively do that. But at a certain point, it runs out of path and then basically repetitively do that. At a certain point, it runs out of stuff and then it just arbitrarily starts choosing a direction. And really what you want is in a certain city, if there is a really, really dense collection of|||因为我在曼谷运行这个算法时，它总是……似乎我的算法应该朝某个方向走，那里有非常密集的节点集合，因为我的算法有一部分是我所谓的“热点搜寻（hot spot seeking）”，因为这不像是我有一个通过迭代工作的贪婪算法，去尝试寻找接下来的 10 步并找到最佳路径，然后基本上重复这个过程。但在某个特定点，它走到了路的尽头，然后基本上重复这个过程。在某个特定点，它用尽了东西，然后它就随意开始选择一个方向。而你真正想要的是，在某个城市里，如果有一个非常非常密集的……
nodes, you want to head towards that. And my algorithm wasn't doing that. And that's because I figured out that in order to get to that place, you needed to go over an overpass over like a highway. And that wasn't being picked up in my initial set of data. Because like it wasn't, out that in order to get to that place you needed to go over an overpass over like a highway and that wasn't being picked up in my initial set of data because like it wasn't because it wasn't uh it wasn't a named path so it wasn't yeah yeah it was like a unnamed you know uh bridge over a highway which yeah doesn't have a name um interesting anyways i haven't really like so the way my algorithm works i mean it's it's like said, we should kick this to a whole, what are we at? We're at the 25 minute mark. And then it's going to calculate at the end of that 10 steps, how many streets did you complete?
nodes, you want to head towards that. And my algorithm wasn't doing that. And that's because I figured out that in order to get to that place, you needed to go over an overpass over like a highway. And that wasn't being picked up in my initial set of data. Because like it wasn't, out that in order to get to that place you needed to go over an overpass over like a highway and that wasn't being picked up in my initial set of data because like it wasn't because it wasn't uh it wasn't a named path so it wasn't yeah yeah it was like a unnamed you know uh bridge over a highway which yeah doesn't have a name um interesting anyways i haven't really like so the way my algorithm works i mean it's it's like said, we should kick this to a whole, what are we at? We're at the 25 minute mark. And then it's calculated at the end of that 10 steps, how many streets did you complete?|||节点集合，你想要朝那个方向前进。而我的算法并没有那样做。那是因为我发现，为了到达那个地方，你需要穿过一座跨越高速公路之类的立交桥。而这并没有被我的初始数据集捕捉到。因为就像它没有……发现为了到达那个地方，你需要穿过一座跨越高速公路的立交桥，而这在我的初始数据集中没有被捕捉到，因为……因为它不是……它不是一条有名字的路径，所以它没有……对，对，它就像是一座无名的、你知道的……跨越高速公路的桥，是的，它没有名字。嗯，有意思。不管怎样，我其实并没有……所以我的算法工作的方式，我是说，就像……正如所说，我们应该把这个推迟到整整一个……我们现在到哪了？我们已经进行到 25 分钟了。然后在接下来的那 10 步结束时，它会计算你完成了多少条街道？
And then it also, it divides the distance, divides by the distance that it took to complete those streets. And then there's a couple other heuristics. And there's some other things that, yeah, get like the hotspot seeking that sort of is an adjustment if you're getting closer to that hotspot. Okay, and do you do this predictive thing because um exploring all possible paths is just like like you need to limit the sphere of
And then it also, it divides the distance, divides by the distance that it took to complete those streets. And then there's a couple other heuristics. And there's some other things that, yeah, get like the hotspot seeking that sort of is an adjustment if you're getting closer to that hotspot. Okay, and do you do this predictive thing because – um exploring all possible paths is just like – like you need to limit the sphere of|||然后它还会用这个数字除以完成这些街道所花费的距离。此外还有几个其他的启发式方法。还有一些其他的东西，是的，比如类似于热点搜寻的东西，如果你离那个热点越来越近，它就会做相应的调整。好的，你做这种预测性的事情是因为——嗯，探索所有可能的路径就像是——就像你需要限制……
what you're looking at right like if you just try to look at like everything yes yeah if i were to just like bfs the like number of steps that it would take to complete a 20k run which would be like roughly like 600 or 700 i'm not sure i'm not certain that depth first search is the the correct tool for you to be like reaching for here i'm not i'm not depth first i'm breadth first but it's breadth first even so even so i'm not sure that's the right tool for you to be searching for hey man if you want to come and fix my algorithm or if some person listening, this is open source on github.com slash code report slash city strides hacking. Well, the thing that might be interesting would us to find a reading list, give each other some homework, and read up a little bit on graph theory,
what you're looking at right like if you just try to look at like everything yes yeah if i were to just like bfs the like number of steps that it would take to complete a 20k run which would be like roughly like 600 or 700 i'm not sure i'm not certain that depth first search is the the correct tool for you to be like reaching for here i'm not i'm not depth first i'm breadth first but it's breadth first even so even so i'm not sure that's the right tool for you to be searching for hey man if you want to come and fix my algorithm or if some person listening, this is open source on github.com slash code report slash city strides hacking. Well, the thing that might be interesting would us to find a reading list, give each other some homework, and read up a little bit on graph theory,|||你所观察的范围，对吧？如果你试图去观察所有东西……是的，是的，如果我要用广度优先搜索（BFS）来跑完全程 20 公里跑步所需的步数，那大概是 600 或 700 步……我不确定、我不敢肯定深度优先搜索（DFS）是你在这里应该使用的正确工具。我不是……我不是深度优先，我是广度优先。但它是广度优先的，即便如此，即便如此，我不确定那是不是供你搜索的正确工具。嘿，老兄，如果你想来修复我的算法，或者如果有任何在听节目的朋友，这个项目是开源的，在 github.com/code-report/city-strides-hacking。嗯，有趣的事情可能是我们找个阅读清单，互相布置点家庭作业，读一读关于图论的书籍，
and see if we can use this problem as a way to teach the dear listener a little bit about graph theory. I say teach. That suggests that we somehow have some knowledge here for us to learn a little bit of graph theory. But I'm certain that there's some applicable literature out there. I mean, I would be surprised if there is some nice, clean algorithm that is exactly what I want because I just don't think it exists. I'm sure there's not something that's exactly what you want, but I'm sure that there's applicable techniques out there that might inspire you towards a more optimal algorithm. And I mean, I think the interesting thing about the problem here is it's this nice mix
and see if we can use this problem as a way to teach the dear listener a little bit about graph theory. I say teach. That suggests that we somehow have some knowledge here for us to learn a little bit of graph theory. But I'm certain that there's some applicable literature out there. I mean, I would be surprised if there is some nice, clean algorithm that is exactly what I want because I just don't think it exists. I'm sure there's not something that's exactly what you want, but I'm sure that there's applicable techniques out there that might inspire you towards a more optimal algorithm. And I mean, I think the interesting thing about the problem here is it's this nice mix|||看看我们能否利用这个问题，向亲爱的听众朋友们传授一点图论知识。我说“传授”，这暗示着我们在这里某种程度上有这方面的知识，其实是我们自己去学习一点图论。但我确信外面有一些适用的文献。我是说，如果有一个完美、干净的算法正好是我想要的，我会感到惊讶，因为我根本不认为它存在。我确信没有完全符合你期望的东西，但我确信外面有适用的技术，可能会启发你找到更优的算法。我的意思是，我觉得这里这个有趣的问题在于，它是……
of optimization theory and graph theory. Yeah, I mean, honestly, I would be less interested to read something from a textbook because I just like, I've read a lot of that stuff or not necessarily from textbooks, but like, you know, Dijkstra's algorithm and Prim and all that stuff and Hamiltonian past. but like you know dykstra's algorithm and prim and all that stuff and hamiltonian past and they're always just so clean it's for this like one
of optimization theory and graph theory. Yeah, I mean, honestly, I would be less interested to read something from a textbook because I just like, I've read a lot of that stuff or not necessarily from textbooks, but like, you know, Dijkstra's algorithm and Prim and all that stuff and Hamiltonian past. but like you know dykstra's algorithm and prim and all that stuff and hamiltonian past and they're always just so clean it's for this like one|||优化理论和图论的绝妙结合。是的，我是说，老实说，我对阅读教科书里的东西兴趣不大，因为我只是……我已经读过很多那种东西了，或者不一定非得是教科书，而是像迪杰斯特拉算法（Dijkstra's algorithm）、普里姆算法（Prim）以及所有那些东西，还有哈密顿路径。但是就像你知道的迪杰斯特拉算法、普里姆算法和所有那些东西，以及哈密顿路径，它们总是那么干净利落，它是为了解决这样一个单一的……
problem whereas this problem is incredibly messy like probably like i would be much more interested to to know the algorithms that like uber and google use yeah like u like Uber or Google Maps. Well, do you know what library Uber uses to accelerate their dispatch routing? I'm going to guess Thrust. They use Thrust. Yeah, they use Thrust. They use Thrust. Back like my first year at NVIDIA,
problem whereas this problem is incredibly messy like probably like i would be much more interested to to know the algorithms that like uber and google use yeah like u like Uber or Google Maps. Well, do you know what library Uber uses to accelerate their dispatch routing? I'm going to guess Thrust. They use Thrust. Yeah, they use Thrust. They use Thrust. Back like my first year at NVIDIA,|||问题而设计的，而这个问题却极其混乱。可能……我会对了解像 Uber 和谷歌所使用的算法更感兴趣，是的，就像 Uber 或谷歌地图。你知道 Uber 使用什么库来加速他们的派单路径规划吗？我猜是 Thrust。他们用的是 Thrust。对，他们用的是 Thrust。他们用的是 Thrust。回到我刚进 NVIDIA 的第一年，
my VP sent me a link to to an article from uber talking about how they use thrust yeah my i mean my guess is like the the algorithms that google maps and like uber use to calculate point a to point b one that's a much simpler problem than like what i'm trying to solve but two they do they have – like the data they – Not necessarily when you throw in things like traffic. No, it's an easier problem. Like root – well, anyways, we can debate whether it is or is not. But the point being is I think that they have a very simplified – You heard it here first, people.
my VP sent me a link to to an article from uber talking about how they use thrust yeah my i mean my guess is like the the algorithms that google maps and like uber use to calculate point a to point b one that's a much simpler problem than like what i'm trying to solve but two they do they have – like the data they – Not necessarily when you throw in things like traffic. No, it's an easier problem. Like root – well, anyways, we can debate whether it is or is not. But the point being is I think that they have a very simplified – You heard it here first, people.|||我的副总裁给我发了一个链接，指向 Uber 的一篇文章，谈论他们是如何使用 Thrust 的。对，我的意思是，我的猜测是，谷歌地图和 Uber 等公司用来计算从 A 点到 B 点的算法，一方面，这比我试图解决的问题要简单得多；另一方面，它们拥有……像它们的数据……当你把交通状况等因素考虑进去时，未必如此。不，这是一个更简单的问题。比如路线——好吧，不管怎样，我们可以争论它到底是不是。但重点是，我认为它们拥有一个非常简化的……各位，你们在这里第一次听到这个说法。
Google Maps, trivial. I said point A to point b is easier to solve than uh what i'm doing like the the you should look at some of the runs and the roots that are generated by my algorithm they're completely somebody who's our listener surely must work on google maps or some equivalent thing or know somebody who does reach out to us let us know we want to talk to you sure i'd love to talk to you but i think my the point that i'm trying to say is that my guess is that they have a very specific graph node set that is for the purposes of generating like each of those paths whether it's uh you know via car via via bicycle, whereas I am using everything.
Google Maps, trivial. I said point A to point b is easier to solve than uh what i'm doing like the the you should look at some of the runs and the roots that are generated by my algorithm they're completely somebody who's our listener surely must work on google maps or some equivalent thing or know somebody who does reach out to us let us know we want to talk to you sure i'd love to talk to you but i think my the point that i'm trying to say is that my guess is that they have a very specific graph node set that is for the purposes of generating like each of those paths whether it's uh you know via car via via bicycle, whereas I am using everything.|||谷歌地图，微不足道。我说过，A 点到 B 点比我正在做的事情更容易解决，比如……你应该看看我的算法生成的一些跑步路线，它们完全……我们的听众中肯定有人在谷歌地图或类似的机构工作，或者认识这样的人，请联系我们，让我们知道，我们想和你们聊聊。当然，我很乐意和你们聊聊，但我认为我想表达的观点是，我猜他们拥有一个非常特定的图节点集，其目的是用于生成每一条路径，无论是开车还是骑自行车，而我使用的是所有东西。
I don't care if I have to hop on a bicycle path in order to complete my nodes. I will do that, right? Like there's... But okay, but how does that make it an easier problem? It just means that you view all roads. It means that like the dimensionality of the data that I'm dealing with
I don't care if I have to hop on a bicycle path in order to complete my nodes. I will do that, right? Like there's... But okay, but how does that make it an easier problem? It just means that you view all roads. It means that like the dimensionality of the data that I'm dealing with|||我才不管我是不是必须跳上一条自行车道来完成我的节点。我都会去做的，对吧？就像有……但是，好吧，但这怎么就让它成为一个更简单的问题了呢？这只意味着你审视了所有的道路。这意味着我所处理的数据的维度……
is massive. I don't know that makes it an easier problem. It's just a question of the compute intensity, the tractability of the problem. Also, too, because I'm running, my graph is undirected. I can go anywhere. When you are designing something,
is massive. I don't know that makes it an easier problem. It's just a question of the compute intensity, the tractability of the problem. Also, too, because I'm running, my graph is undirected. I can go anywhere. When you are designing something,|||是巨大的。我不知道这是否让它变成了一个更简单的问题。这只是一个计算强度、问题可解性的问题。而且，同样因为我在跑步，我的图是无向的。我可以去任何地方。当你设计某些东西时，
your edges have directions, like the dimensionality of a point. You do have to start and end. I don't even have an end. Uh, that's like a to do feature. My right now, when, if I want to run 20 K I'll just put 15 K in and then I'll run the last five K back. Uh, because adding, adding an end point, which is typically quite close to the start. if you're traveling, like you're starting at your hotel, ending at your hotel, that complicates it drastically. Because basically, you're going to be going out one direction. And the easiest way is once you hit the halfway point, you then start adding in some reward for closing the distance back to where you started.
your edges have directions, like the dimensionality of a point. You do have to start and end. I don't even have an end. Uh, that's like a to do feature. My right now, when, if I want to run 20 K I'll just put 15 K in and then I'll run the last five K back. Uh, because adding, adding an end point, which is typically quite close to the start. if you're traveling, like you're starting at your hotel, ending at your hotel, that complicates it drastically. Because basically, you're going to be going out one direction. And the easiest way is once you hit the halfway point, you then start adding in some reward for closing the distance back to where you started.|||你的边是有方向的，就像一个点的维度一样。你必须有起点和终点。我甚至连终点都没有。呃，那就像是一个待开发的功能。我现在，当……如果我想跑 20 公里，我就会输入 15 公里，然后我再跑最后 5 公里回来。呃，因为添加一个终点（通常离起点很近）——如果你在出行，比如你从酒店出发，在酒店结束——会大大增加问题的复杂性。因为基本上，你要朝一个方向出发。最简单的方法是，一旦你到达中点，你就可以开始增加一些奖励机制，以缩短回到起点的距离。
Well, let me ask you an interesting question. Suppose if you lived in a world, if this problem, if this problem was small enough, or you lived in a world where compute power and storage was infinitely cheap, how would it change how you solve this problem? I would have the exact same algorithm. You just increase the step count. Like the main thing that I need to do to improve this algorithm, in my opinion, is to parallelize the BFS.
Well, let me ask you an interesting question. Suppose if you lived in a world, if this problem, if this problem was small enough, or you lived in a world where compute power and storage was infinitely cheap, how would it change how you solve this problem? I would have the exact same algorithm. You just increase the step count. Like the main thing that I need to do to improve this algorithm, in my opinion, is to parallelize the BFS.|||好吧，让我问你一个有趣的问题。假设如果你生活在一个世界里——如果这个问题、如果这个问题足够小，或者你生活在一个计算能力和存储无限廉价的世界里——这将如何改变你解决这个问题的方式？我会使用完全相同的算法。你只需要增加步数。就像我认为为了改进这个算法我需要做的最主要的事情，就是将 BFS 并行化。
Because right now I'm limited to like eight to 12 steps, which still gets me pretty fantastic results. But there are cases where, I mean, it would just... And by steps here, I think you may want to clarify, you don't mean actual steps, but you mean like an edge... Iterations of BFS, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Of the BFS.
Because right now I'm limited to like eight to 12 steps, which still gets me pretty fantastic results. But there are cases where, I mean, it would just... And by steps here, I think you may want to clarify, you don't mean actual steps, but you mean like an edge... Iterations of BFS, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Of the BFS.|||因为目前我被限制在大概 8 到 12 步，这仍然能给我带来相当棒的结果。但在某些情况下，我的意思是，它只会……而且这里说的“步”，我想你可能需要澄清一下，你指的不是真正的走路步数，而是指像一条边……BFS 的迭代次数，对吧？对，对。BFS 的迭代。
So you pass in some integer and then it gets decremented until it hits zero. But it represents how many segments? It represents how many choices you make. Right, right, okay. So technically a part of the algorithm initially was if you are on a street that only has one node in front of you and one node behind you, always go forward. Because you don't want to be – if you're in a street that's curved and has 50 nodes in it, but it's only half a kilometer, and every single time you move forward, you then, you consider a choice being, do I go backwards or do I go forwards?
So you pass in some integer and then it gets decremented until it hits zero. But it represents how many segments? It represents how many choices you make. Right, right, okay. So technically a part of the algorithm initially was if you are on a street that only has one node in front of you and one node behind you, always go forward. Because you don't want to be – if you're in a street that's curved and has 50 nodes in it, but it's only half a kilometer, and every single time you move forward, you then, you consider a choice being, do I go backwards or do I go forwards?|||所以你传入一个整数，然后它会递减，直到达到零.但它代表了多少段？它代表你做了多少次选择。对，对，好吧。所以在技术上，该算法最初的一部分是：如果你在一条前面只有一个节点、后面也只有一个节点的街道上，永远向前走。因为你不想——如果你在一条弯曲且有 50 个节点的街道上，但它只有半公里长，而且每次你向前移动时，你接着……你把一个选择视为：我是往回走还是往前走？
Then you go forwards again. Do I go backwards or do I go forwards? And exploring that, because then you just destroy your ability to make progress. However, always going forward, if you're on basically a street where you're not at an intersection where you have options isn't optimal because at some times you want to basically just get a node
然后你再次前进。我是该往后走还是往前走？去探索这一点，因为这样你就会彻底毁掉自己取得进展的能力。然而，如果你基本上是在一条没有选择交叉口的街道上，总是往前走并不是最优解，因为有时你基本上只是想到达一个
that's like 10 meters in front of you but then the next node is like half a kilometer away and as soon as you take that first step to the one that's 10 meters away you then are forced to go half a kilometer to the next direction so you basically want to have some...
在前方10米左右的节点，但接下来的节点却在半公里之外，而一旦你迈出第一步去往那个10米外的节点，你就会被迫向下一个方向前进半公里，所以你基本上希望拥有某种……
Like what direction is forward? Direction when you're on a street that only has a node in front of you and a node behind you where there's basically no option other than keep going forward or reverse direction and go back where you came from. What do you mean by direction? Well, you're running. You're running. I'm a runner. I'm running forward.
就像什么方向才是前方？当你身处一条前方只有一个节点、后方也只有一个节点，除了继续向前或调头回到你来的地方之外别无选择的街道时，方向是什么意思？你所说的方向是什么意思？好吧，你在跑步。你在跑步。我是一个跑步者。我在向前跑。
Most people run for i understand there's no there's no direction like north east west south it's just i'm running to the next node but when i think about this problem what i would imagine is that your position wouldn't have a particular orientation all right so let me simplify this in general you can think of when you're this algorithm or when you're running, you're in two different possible situations. Situation one, you're at an intersection or you're at some place on a map where you have multiple options where you can go, you know, make a left-hand turn, right-hand turn, you know, keep going forward. If you've got some stairs that you can go up, you know, you could have upwards of, you know, like 10, 11, 12 different directions. But on average, you usually have like three or four. Or you are on a road where you can either, you technically
大多数人跑步是为了——我明白，这里没有什么东北西北这样的方向，我只是在跑向下一个节点。但当我思考这个问题时，我想象的是你的位置不会有特定的朝向。好吧，让我简化一下。通常你可以认为，当你运行这个算法或者当你跑步时，你处于两种可能的情况之一。情况一：你处在一个交叉口，或者地图上的某个地方，在那里你有多种可以去选择的方向，比如，你可以向左转、向右转，或者继续向前。如果你有一些可以上去的楼梯，你知道的，你可能会有多达10个、11个、12个不同的方向。但平均来说，通常有三四个。或者你处在这样一条路上：从技术上讲，你确实
do have two options. You can continue to go the direction that you're currently going, or you can turn around. And as I mentioned before, you don't want to be in a situation where every single time you're going down this road in a direction, you're making a decision. Should I reverse direction or keep going forward? If you're doing that every single time, you're going to completely destroy your ability to make progress in this algorithm.
有两个选择。你可以继续朝目前的方向前进，或者你可以转身。正如我之前提到的，你不会希望陷入这样一种情况：每次你顺着这条路朝某个方向前进时，你都要做一个决定。我是应该掉头还是继续向前？如果你每次都这样做，你将彻底摧毁在这个算法中取得进展的能力。
So I have a threshold that says you're only allowed to backtrack if the next node in front of you is further away above a certain distance. I think on average I have that set to like 200 meters. So you're allowed to backtrack. You're allowed to make the option to turn around and reverse direction. If the next node on this street where you only have two options, that's continuing to go forward and to go backward, is greater than 200 meters.
所以我设置了一个阈值，规定只有当前方下一个节点的距离超过一定距离时，你才被允许往回走。我想我平均将其设置为200米左右。所以你是被允许往回走的。如果你在这条只有两个选择（即继续向前和向后走）的街道上，下一个节点的距离大于200米，你就可以选择掉头并反向行驶。
Otherwise, you have to keep going forward if it's only five meters away. Okay. When you talk about orientation, like, is it assumed that you have some knowledge of where you came from and that therefore the, or like, you know, I, okay. Yes, you have a path. You have a path that is defined by a set of nodes and the node that is at the top of that path or the back of the path is where you just were. And so you can prevent yourself from revisiting that by checking the nodes that I'm about to explore are always going to contain the node that you just came from. And in certain situations, you want to make sure that you're not just always, like I said, destroying your ability to make progress because you only have a certain number of choices. Like I said, the steps that
否则，如果它只有5米远，你就必须继续向前。好吧。当谈到朝向时，比如说，是不是假设你对你来自哪里有所了解，因此，或者说，你知道，我——好的。是的，你有一条路径。你有一条由一组节点定义的路径，该路径顶部或后方的节点就是你刚刚所在的那个地方。因此，通过检查我即将探索的节点是否总是包含你刚离开的节点，你可以防止自己重新访问那个地方。在某些情况下，正如我所说，你希望确保自己不会总是毁掉取得进展的能力，因为你只有一定数量的选择。就像我说的，你所迈出的步伐
you make are really the choices that you make. So when you choose to take a left-hand turn or right-hand turn or, you know, go across an intersection, that reduces your number of choices. And if you're always including your ability to go backwards, I guess it's not going to make it impossible for you to make progress. But it's just, it explodes the dimensionality by like increasing, you know, the factor of N that your tree is growing out by.
实际上就是你所做出的选择。因此，当你选择左转、右转或者穿过一个十字路口时，这会减少你的选择数量。如果你总是把往回走的能力也计算在内，我想这不会使你无法取得进展。但这只会极大地增加维度，让你的树生长的 N 的因子成倍增加。
Every node gets N plus five. So I have a couple of logistical questions, lighthearted questions. Humorous questions. Color commentary. I have some color commentary. All right. Go ahead.
每个节点都会得到 N 加五。所以我有几个后勤方面的问题，轻松愉快的问题。幽默的问题。插话。我有一些插话。好吧。请讲。
So are you out there running and then you stop and you pull out your laptop and you type in where you need to go next? I, 95% of the time while I run, have my cell phone in hand, screen turned on, and am looking at it like every 10 seconds. Yes. And are running your algorithm? No, the algorithm is run in advance and generates the root. And the root is defined by a bunch of nodes that are latitude and longitude coordinates. And you can just... I think it would have been funnier if you were building it as you go. No. I mean, my roots are ridiculous, though. Like, the number of 180-degree turns and the areas that it takes me.
所以你会出去跑步，然后停下来，掏出笔记本电脑，输入你接下来要去哪里？我跑步时，95% 的时间手机都在手里，屏幕亮着，每10秒左右就要看一次。是的。然后在运行你的算法？不，算法是提前运行并生成路线的。路线由一堆经纬度坐标节点定义。你可以直接……我觉得如果你边跑边建（路线）会更有趣。不。不过，我的路线确实很荒唐。比如，180度转弯的数量以及它带我去的地方。
Like, when I was in Bangkok, there was this one – When were you in Bangkok? I was in Bangkok recently. My good friend, congratulations to Ethan and his partner, got married in Vietnam. Oh, yeah. You mentioned this to me. Yeah. So I was over in Bangkok recently. My good friend, congratulations to Ethan and his partner, got married in Vietnam. Oh, yeah. You mentioned this to me. Yeah.
比如，我在曼谷的时候，有这么一个——你什么时候去的曼谷？我最近去了曼谷。我的好朋友，祝贺伊万和他的伴侣在越南结婚。哦，对。你跟我提过这个。对。所以前阵子我在东南亚。基本上，我就是沿着一条街道跑，然后突然钻进这些50米长的小街里，一共有28条。所以在大约两公里的路程里，我完成了30条街道。平均来说，我可以说，
And so I was over in Southeast Asia. And basically, I was just running down a street and then ducking into these like 50-meter streets of which there were 28 of them. So in like a two-kilometer stretch, I completed 30 streets. And like on average, I would say the the bare minimum depending on what city you're in you want like 10 streets per five kilometers um but a good run like my best run was 225 streets in 20 kilometers which was where was that that was in venice um yeah and which is why this brings me back to milan i've also i've been slowly i you know the amount of data that you i though i got
根据你所在的城市不同，你最希望每五公里大约有10条街道，但一次好的跑步——我最好的一次跑步是在20公里内跑了225条街道，那是在哪里？那是威尼斯，嗯，是的，这也是为什么这让我想到了米兰。我也一直在慢慢地，你知道，你所拥有的数据量，虽然我懂——
i gotta tell i gotta tell you i love milan as a city but the the streets in milan absolutely terrible doesn't matter i'll be running them all i care about all i care about is the nose. Seriously, it was bad enough that I took a scooter or one of the e-bikes once, and I was like, I'm not doing this again. And then just getting my luggage, rolling my luggage five to ten minutes between places I was staying in train stations was just such a hassle just because of the quality of the sidewalks in the streets. I mean, I loved everything about Italy, but Milan, you need to, you need to work on your streets. Also their, their, their curb cuts in, in Milan, like they have like a pretty noticeable bump on the curb cut, which like,
我得说，我得说，我爱米兰这座城市，但米兰的街道实在太糟糕了。没关系，我会把它们全都跑完的。我关心的全部，我关心的只有那些节点。说真的，情况太糟糕了，以至于我有一次坐了滑板车或电单车，当时我就想，我再也不这么干了。然后仅仅是拿行李，在我住的地方和火车站之间推行李5到10分钟，就成了一件非常麻烦的事，仅仅是因为街道上人行道的质量。我的意思是，我喜欢意大利的一切，但米兰，你们真得，你们真得好好整整你们的街道。还有，米兰的那些，那些，那些路缘斜坡，它们的斜坡上有一个相当明显的颠簸，这意味着，
if you, if you're, you have some wheeled thing that you need to get noticeable bump on the curb cut which like if you if you're you have some wheeled thing that you need to get onto or off the curb having a big bump like sort of defeats the purpose of your curb cut but i i have some other color commentary questions so how many times has this algorithm gotten you lost never uh the the never the footnote on that answer is that I never get lost because I've got a phone in my hand with GPS. However, it has told me to run places that it is not possible to run, probably the worst of which was once again when I was in Bangkok in Thailand. It wanted me to run onto a military compound, and the men with guns at the entrance of this military compound.
如果你，如果你有某种带轮子的东西需要推上或推下路缘，有一个大颠簸某种程度上就违背了你设置路缘斜坡的初衷。不过我还有其他一些插话的问题。所以这个算法让你迷路过多少次？从不。呃，那个回答的附注是，我从不迷路，因为我手里拿着有GPS的手机。不过，它确实让我去过一些根本不可能跑步的地方，其中最糟糕的可能还是我在泰国曼谷的时候。它想让我跑进一个军事大院，而这个军事大院入口处有带枪的守卫。
I clearly did not try to run in, but it was apparent that when I got to that part of the map, I was taking a little detour. Well, I was just about to ask, how sketchy of a, like, have you built into your algorithm, like, the sketchiness of the neighborhoods? No, no. I will say, though, it is. Is this going to be what we're going to put on your tombstone? It's like Connor was in some city and he ran into the bad neighborhood because the algorithm killed him. It's not for the faint of heart, though, because a lot of the times you are running into a definitely like a residential street that is a dead end and people are staring at you being like what are you doing running down my residential
我显然没有试图跑进去，但很明显，当我到达地图的那一部分时，我是在进行一次小小的绕道。嗯，我正要问，你有没有把社区的危险程度写入你的算法中？没有，没有。不过我要说的是，这会成为刻在你墓碑上的话吗？就像“康纳在某个城市里，因为算法害死了他，所以跑进了不安全社区”。这可不是胆小的人能玩的，因为很多时候你跑进的绝对是一条死胡同般的住宅街，人们会盯着你看，心里想：“你在我的住宅街上跑步到底在干什么？”
street and then you kind of have to pretend that or at least i do because i feel bad but like i'm looking for a way through and then i realize oh it's a dead end and then i i they they kind of point to you know you got to go that way and And I'm like, oh, thank you, thank you. Especially for the ones where it's like, you know, it's a 20-meter street that I'm going just to complete because it's short. So, yeah, no sketchy neighborhoods. There's been a couple of streets that I've skipped, though. Are you going to do this when we're in Nigeria? Yeah, why not?
然后你不得不假装——或者至少我是这样，因为我觉得很不好意思——假装我在找一条能穿过去的通途，然后我意识到，哦，原来是个死胡同，接着他们就会指着某个方向，示意“你得往那边走”。然后我就说：“哦，谢谢，谢谢。”特别是那些只有20米长、我为了“集齐”它而特意去跑的街道。所以，是的，没有什么危险社区。不过确实有几条街道我跳过了。等我们去尼日利亚的时候，你也会这么做吗？对，为什么不呢？
Morocco? I mean why not? Morocco? I mean, I think Morocco, they have rules, though. Like, you can't actually – I mean, I'm not going to put my life on the line. Well, I mean, it actually depends on what the mortality rate would be. I'm not going to seriously put my life on the line. I mean, I've been running next to highways that is probably not advised. I've definitely been running places that, you know, and also I'm listening to my podcast while I'm doing it. So I've got my headphones in and,
摩洛哥？我的意思是为什么不呢？摩洛哥？我的意思是，我觉得在摩洛哥，他们是有规矩的。比如，你不能真的——我的意思是，我不会把自己的命搭进去。好吧，我的意思是，这其实取决于死亡率会是多少。我不会真的把自己的命搭进去。我的意思是，我曾经在高速公路旁跑步，这可能是不被建议的。我绝对在一些地方跑过，你知道的，而且我在跑步的时候还在听播客。所以塞着耳机，
you know. Yes. So it's a great situational awareness. Yeah. I mean, but listen, listen, you got to have life goals. And my current life goal is to be number one on this website. And it's going to happen, folks. This is your current life goal well look i i can't complain because my current life goals revolve around uh flying and spending money on on ridiculous we all have we all have the things that make us make us happy anyways we're at the 43 minute mark we haven't even we have this is a long episode. So we got to – let's skip over to the two things I was going to mention. Episode 143, we mentioned R, and we got a comment on Twitter. Also, we're not calling it X.com.
你知道的。是的。所以这真是一种极佳的情境意识。是的。但听着，听着，人总得有生活目标。我目前的生活目标就是成为这个网站的头名。这一定会实现的，伙计们。这是你目前的生活目标。好吧，我——我没什么可抱怨的，因为我目前的生活目标围绕着——飞行，以及把钱花在荒唐的——我们都有，我们都有那些让我们感到快乐的事情。总之，我们已经到了43分钟大关，我们甚至还没有——这是一个很长的单集。所以我们得——让我们跳到我要提到的两件事。第143期节目，我们提到了R语言，我们在推特上收到了一条评论。另外，我们不叫它X.com。
Maybe others will. It's going to be Twitter. You know, I feel like not enough people are with us on this, but I'm sorry. You don't just get to rename, rename a thing because you bought it. Nope. Yeah. I heard that actually, I heard on another podcast today that Elon Musk has a biography. He already has a biography or auto, not autobiography, but a biography written by Ashley Vance. Musk, terrible person, fired his secretary after 20 years. You know, anybody that looks up to him, you should go read his, go read Ashley Vance's book. And, but apparently, uh, Walter Isaacson, the individual
也许其他人会叫吧。它将永远是推特。你知道，我觉得没有足够多的人在这件事上站在我们这边，但对不起。你不能仅仅因为你买下了一个东西，就随随便便给它改名。没错。是的。我听说，事实上，我今天在另一个播客里听到埃隆·马斯克有一本传记。他已经有一本传记了，或者说自传——不是自传，而是一本由阿什利·万斯（Ashley Vance）写的传记。马斯克，一个糟糕的人，在20年后解雇了他的秘书。你知道的，任何崇拜他的人，都应该去读读他的书，去读读阿什利·万斯的书。而且，显然，沃尔特·艾萨克森（Walter Isaacson），也就是
behind the Steve Jobs biography and a couple other books has written one about Elon Musk. I will be consuming that ASAP. Anyways, we're going to call this website Twitter because screw that guy. And until we get some like Gen Xers or whatever, the kids, you know, until they're asking us what is Twitter and we start getting like active comments that we're confusing our listeners by calling it Twitter, we're calling it Twitter because I'm not calling it X.com. But calling it Twitter really – it's not just because like screw Elon. But also just, like, it's a dumb name. Like, and there was no need to rename the thing. So we're going to keep calling it Twitter. And also, we're not going anywhere. We're not leaving.
史蒂夫·乔布斯传记以及其他几本书的幕后作者，写了一本关于埃隆·马斯克的书。我会尽快去拜读的。总之，我们要把这个网站叫做推特，因为去他的。除非我们吸引到一些X世代或者别的什么人，也就是那些孩子们，你知道的，直到他们开始问我们什么是推特，直到我们开始收到活跃的评论，说我们叫它推特把听众搞糊涂了为止，我们都会叫它推特，因为我才不叫它X.com。但是叫它推特真的——不仅仅是因为“去他的埃隆”。也是因为，这名字太蠢了。而且根本没有必要给这东西改名。所以我们要继续叫它推特。而且，我们哪儿也不去。我们不会离开。
You know what? You can rename it. You can do all the stupid things you want. Connor and I are persistent. We're here. We're not leaving. This is our're here we're not leaving this is our space I will say that if
你知道吗？你可以改名。你可以做所有你想做的愚蠢事情。康纳和我都很执着。我们就在这里。我们不会离开。这是我们的——我们在这里，我们不会离开，这是我们的地盘。我要说的是，如果
Mastodon or Blueski I know it's called Blue Sky but I heard someone say Blueski and I thought that was funny anyways if there is some viable alternative that actually isn't just like some nascent thing like I'm down to switch because I've heard enough people complaining about how the I refuse to let this man win I would rather thing like i'm down to switch because i've heard enough people complaining about how the i i i
Mastodon或者Blueski——我知道它叫Blue Sky，但我听人说过Blueski，我觉得这挺搞笑的——总之，如果有什么切实可行的替代方案，而不仅仅是什么刚诞生的东西，我是愿意切换的，因为我听过足够多的人抱怨——我拒绝向这个人低头，我宁愿——是什么刚诞生的东西，我是愿意切换的，因为我听过足够多的人抱怨——我——
refuse to let this man win i would rather stay here and bitch and moan and call him stupid and let him make a fool of himself until eventually he moves on or whatever let me let me let me like let me make my point though which is it is undeniable that the experience people are having on Twitter is degrading like at a serious rate. I've had people – multiple people say that they no longer see our tweets about the episodes. Like people are missing the content they want to see. Like the experience on Twitter is actually like getting worse and worse and worse. Since Elon has taken over, my follower count has like frozen too. Like nobody that I know in like the C++ Twitter sphere has really increased substantially in follower count since Elon took over. Like I still see some people's tweets,
我拒绝向这个人低头，我宁愿留在这里发牢骚、抱怨，叫他大傻瓜，让他出丑，直到他最终离开或者怎样。不过，让我——让我——让我把话说完，那就是不可否认的是，人们在推特上的体验正在恶化——而且速度相当惊人。我有人——好几个人说他们再也看不到我们关于节目的推文了。就像人们错过了他们想看的内容。推特上的体验实际上变得越来越糟。自从埃隆接管以来，我的粉丝数量也冻结了。我在C++推特圈里认识的任何人，粉丝数量自埃隆接管以来都没有实质性增长。我仍然能看到某些人的推文，
but like that fact, I think says a lot about like whatever he's doing with the algorithm and just the degree to which they promote the random, you know, Twitter blue people over actual contributing members of the Twitter community. Yeah. So my point is, yes, I agree.
但这个事实，我认为很能说明问题，无论他对算法做了什么，以及他们将随机的、你知道的推特蓝V用户置于推特社区真正贡献者之上的程度有多严重。所以我的意思是，是的，我同意。
We're sticking. We're staying. But like once there is a viable alternative, I'm happy to switch at this point. That just doesn't exist. That being said. I would think about it, but I'm very stubborn and I still firmly believe, firmly believe that at some point this man is going to get bored of this and uh things will go back to the way they are that that being said before we get to you know i've been trying to read
我们不走。我们留下来。但一旦出现切实可行的替代话，我随时准备切换。目前只是不存在这样的替代方案。话虽如此。我会考虑的，但我非常顽固，并且我坚信——坚信在某个时候这个人会对此感到厌倦，事情会恢复原样。话虽如此，在我们讨论——你知道的，我一直在试着读
andrew's tweet here for you know 10 minutes i was just uh when i was posting our most recent episode 148 on linkedin i noticed we actually have more followers on linkedin on our linkedin page than we do on twitter so you know what we already have a second home shout out to all the folks that follow us on LinkedIn oh god do I have to start caring about my LinkedIn now how many followers do we have on LinkedIn I can't remember the exact number was roughly 2,500 and I think on Twitter we have like roughly 21 or 2,000 or something like that how many followers do I have on LinkedIn? I don't know. Anyways. But is it more than you?
安德鲁在这里的推文，已经10分钟了——我只是在把我们最新的第148期节目发布到领英（LinkedIn）上时，我注意到我们在领英主页上的粉丝其实比推特上的还要多。所以，你知道吗，我们已经有了第二个家。向所有在领英上关注我们的朋友们大声喊出谢意！哦天哪，我现在得开始关心我的领英了吗？我们在领英上有多少粉丝？我不记得确切数字了，大约是2500，我记得在推特上我们大概有21000还是2000，或者类似的东西。我在领英上有多少粉丝？我不知道。总之。但比你的多吗？
Wrapping, probably. Wrapping up. That's all the men. Wrapping up. Andrew Craig. It's more than JF. Episode 143, when we talked about R, and Andrew says on Twitter, my two favorite languages are R and Q,
差不多吧。总算快结束了。这就是所有人。总算快结束了。安德鲁·克雷格（Andrew Craig）。比JF的多。在第143期节目中，当我们讨论R语言时，安德鲁在推特上说，我最喜欢的两种语言是R和Q，
so I was happy to hear R discussed, even if not very positively. In R's defense, the built-in pipe is pipe greater than, which is the pizza operator. And the built-in outer product is percent O percent. I agree that it would have been nice to have had a separate scan function. And I did not know that. And I think actually I replied at some point, maybe on a different thread. The point being, though, is I was whining about the pipeline operator, which I believe was percent something percent. It was a percent sandwich, and it was three characters, and it looked awful.
所以我很高兴听到讨论R，即使这种讨论并不是非常积极。为了捍卫R语言，内置的管道是“大于号管道”，这就是披萨运算符。内置的外积是百分号O百分号。我同意如果能有一个单独的扫描函数会更好。我以前并不知道这一点。我想实际上我在某个时候回复过，可能是在另一个帖子上。不过重点是，我当时在抱怨管道操作符，我相信它是百分号什么什么百分号。它是一个百分号三明治，有三个字符，看起来太糟糕了。
Apparently, that's actually a library pipeline operator, which is why it's so ugly. And the built-in pipe operator, which came in like a very recent version of R, I can't, 3.x, something like that, is actually the same one that is getting proposed, although it kind of died, which is going to bring us, if we're still recording, because I'd like to record one more episode, to episode, is it going to be, I think it's going to be 150. We're going to release 149 as an extra long 50-minute episode. My topic for 150, which is a pretty big number, is going to be exciting. I've done some prep.
显然，那实际上是一个库管道操作符，这就是为什么它那么丑。而内置管道操作符是在R语言的某个非常新（我记不清了，3.x之类的版本）的版本中引入的，其实它和那个被提议但有点夭折的管道是同一个。这将把我们带到——如果我们还在录音的话，因为我想再录一期节目——第几期来着？我想应该是第150期。我们将发布第149期作为长达50分钟的超长节目。我为第150期准备的话题——这是一个相当大的数字——将会非常令人兴奋。我已经做了一些准备。
I've got some podcast clips to let Bryce listen to. We're going to get his live reactions. Anyways, the topic, spoiler, you're going to have to wait a week, is going to be, is C++ dying? A little bit of clickbait.
我准备了一些播客剪辑让布莱斯听。我们要获取他实时的反应。无论如何，这个话题，剧透一下，你们得等上一周，那就是：C++正在消亡吗？有点标题党。
A little bit of clickbait. Going to go with yes. Wait till episode 150, though, folks. Anyways, thank you for the comment, Andrew. And we are going to have someone from R. We've gotten a couple different suggestions. And it is very heartwarming to know that the pizza operator is the actual language one. And the one that I was talking about is the library one. That brings us to episode 142, when we were talking about Rust and
有点标题党。我选“是”。不过，伙计们，等看到第150期就知道了。总之，谢谢安德鲁的评论。我们将会请来一位精通R语言的嘉宾。我们收到了几个不同的建议。得知披萨运算符是真正的语言内置运算符，而我之前谈论的是库运算符，这让人感到非常暖心。这就把我们带到了第142期节目，当时我们正在讨论Rust，
a solution to a problem that involved calling dot cars on a slice, I think, a string slice. And john-littlebarelabs on GitHub in one of our GitHub discussions replied saying that as to why it doesn't call cars, because I think you asked how come you can't just call.itter on a string slice, and you have to go.cars and then.itter. And the answer is that he provides or they provide is as to why it doesn't call cars for you, it doesn't want to make assumptions about what you mean versus UTF-8 versus bytes. And so he gives, or they give a couple different links. And the sort of highlights are that string slices are always valid UTF-8. And you have to sort of specify what that means. So what exactly
以及一个涉及对切片（我指的是字符串切片）调用`.chars`的问题。在我们的一个GitHub讨论中，GitHub用户john-littlebarelabs回复了解释为什么它不直接调用`.chars`——因为我想你当时问过为什么不能直接在字符串切片上调用`.iter`，而必须先调用`.chars`再调用`.iter`。他或他们给出的答案是，为什么它不为你调用`.chars`的原因是，它不想对你的意图做出假设，即你指的是UTF-8还是字节。所以他（或他们）给出了几个不同的链接。其中的亮点大致是：字符串切片始终是有效的UTF-8。你必须说明这到底意味着什么。那么，
does it mean to iterate over UTF-8? You can specify what you mean with a method. And then there's the.cars method, but then they also provide an analog.bytes. And by byte, they mean the code units, aka 8-bit octets. Rust terminology often makes a reasonable car bit assumption. Anyways, there's a bunch of links. We will put it in the show notes. Thank you for the comments from both Andrew and John. Anything you'd like to say to wrap up episode 149? Bryce has just taken photos with Looney. I tell you, man, you got to bring a higher level
遍历UTF-8到底意味着什么？你可以用一个方法来明确你的意图。然后有`.chars`方法，但他们还提供了一个对应的`.bytes`方法。所谓字节，指的是代码单元，也就是8位八位组。Rust术语通常会做出合理的汽车/字节（car bit）假设。总之，里面有一堆链接。我们会把它放在本期节目的shownotes中。感谢安德鲁和约翰的评论。关于总结第149期节目，你有什么想说的吗？布莱斯刚刚和露尼（Looney）拍了照。我跟你说，老兄，你得给这个播客带来更高水平
of professionalism to this pod. She lied down on me. Fascinating to know that we spent a good chunk of an episode talking to the pipeline operator without realizing that it was a library functionality, not the built-in one. So thank you for keeping us honest, dear listener. Yeah, I think that's my comment.
的专业精神。她刚才趴在我身上。很高兴知道我们花了整整一期节目的大部分时间来讨论管道操作符，却没有意识到它是库的功能，而不是内置功能。所以谢谢你让我们保持清醒，亲爱的听众。是的，我想这就是我的评论。
All right. Wrapping episode 149. be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a github discussion where you can leave comments thoughts or questions thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day low quality high quantity that is the tagline of our podcast it's not the tagline our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好了，第149期节目到此结束。请务必查看你的播客应用中的shownotes，或者访问adspthepodcast.com，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及可以留下评论、想法或问题的GitHub讨论链接。谢谢收听，希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。低质量，高质量，这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语，我们的标语是“带有信息点缀的混乱”。本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。